I believe that this nation should commit
itself to achieving the goal before this
decade is out of landing a man on the
moon
[Music]
[Music]
yesterday's got the flag up now and
you're gonna do the photo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm landing in the Mojave Desert to meet
Sir Richard Branson and his Virgin
Galactic headquarters this is where the
famous billionaire is pouring hundreds
of millions of dollars into building a
rocket ship
so civilians can travel into space very
few people have ever been to this place
and I'm dying to see what's inside
Richard Mike good to see you again well
welcome to our whoa so this is it this
is the spaceship this is huge
yeah the spaceship is not enormous but
it takes eight people to pilot six
passengers exactly what you're looking
at is Virgin Galactic's mothership the
spacecraft is the fuselage at the center
it's attached to this giant carrier jet
that flies it high up into the
atmosphere and this craft will take it
up to 50,000 feet and then they will
release the spaceship three two one
release release release then what
happens he has the rocket fire fire that
takes it up into space you then hold on
for dear life and it goes 3,000 miles an
hour in eight seconds straight up into
space the ride of your lifetime even
more impressive is the fact that Branson
already has a long list of people who
dropped two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars to get onboard 700 people have
given you a quarter of a million dollars
apiece that's about 89 million dollars
you have a guesstimation when this would
be profitable about 18 months time
approximately I would say that's soon
yeah the moment we can start sending
people to space which is likely to be at
the end of the year we'll start making
money back among the 700 are some really
big names you've recognized reportedly
Justin Bieber Katy Perry and Brad Pitt
signed up for this six-figure ride-along
you up there for him so the whole the
whole trips about three and a half hours
be amount of time in space is not
massive maybe 10 minutes and are you
weightless at that time unbuckle you
float about we've got big windows you
can look back in the air
it costs 250 K for a seat which buys you
about 10 minutes in space that comes up
to 25,000 smackeroos per minute
everybody wants to see inside that thing
I'm not leaving why tomorrow this goes
to space and I just wouldn't what I
wouldn't want you to touch anything I'll
take my shoes off before I go it's very
kind of you well we'll take the shoes
they look they're quite nice soon for me
personally it's less about being the
first kid on the block I want to see
other people survive this thing and when
they do I definitely want to get in that
spaceship and become an astronaut we're
now having seen it I've got the bug good
yeah I look forward lighting up there I
want a deal I'm not paying it would take
it out there would we push him out I
think so are you in or out subscribe to
my channel you know what happens you'll
be dead to me
[Music]